oh haha Nick get it and this is my ball  Nick Cannon launches a YouTube channel  after leaving America's Got Talent  mother wit from NBC today in it daddy I  don't seem like a upwardly mobile move  the TV personalities first video runs  more than eight minutes it's an  expletive filled rant and addresses  everything from politics to farts and  his own mental health you know what to  be brilliant to be a genius to change  the world you have to be crazy  EG was with nick in december behind the  scenes of his comedy special taping and  he told us he's at a point in his career  where nothing is off-limits  i feel like there's so much more to my  life than just that aspect so so you  gonna hear more of a point of view on on  life and where we are with politics and  and our community but of course i'm  gonna be wiling out a little bit too and  talking about being single talking about  other ladies all that values everything  isn't it  [Music]  you